Pro Football Hall of Famer how he long
still to come here on the show as you
know when we go off to Miami for the
Super Bowl
we'll have that whole CSI Miami theme
our es Miami thing we're very very
excited about that
also as you know and we have all our
guests stopped by once you know while we
will turn our attention to the end of
the Year awards on the NFL honors and
that means it's time to start setting
the table on that the FedEx air and
FedEx Ground air and Player of the Year
nominees are out and the man to help us
walk through all of that as well as get
us set for a little bit more football
this weekend is a longtime friend and a
good friend of the program three-time
Pro Bowl quarterback Carson Palmer how
are you Carson I'm rich I'm great how
are you I am doing better for talking to
you doing better where do we start let's
let's start I guess with um with these
nominees let's just jump right into it
how does despite the Holmes and Wilson
being on this list
how does Lamar not win this one when we
were all expecting to be MVP Carson I
mean how does he not win both I mean
here such a great year on the ground too
he had almost years some of the ground
nominees but yeah I mean it's it's I
mean Russell Wilson's years been
unbelievable Patrick mahomes was hurt
for you know essentially two and a half
games and still was spectacular
statistically so you know it's it's
that's what's so great about it is it's
voted on and and awarded by the fans
to the to the winner so it's it's so
important for the fans to vote and and
they can vote by logging on to the NFL
Twitter page or nfl.com / FedEx Patrick
mahomes won it I feel like he won it
last year in week 7 I mean he just
ripped off a 50 touchdown years 5000
plus yards it was amazing
this year it wasn't you know as dramatic
especially with the injury but will
Lamar did through the air and on the
ground it was just a spectacular year
for the barn and the Baltimore Ravens
you make a good point I think they just
the folks at FedEx and the NFL just want
to give Derek Henry Nick Chubb and
Christian McCaffrey their due and not
put Lamar in the
in category either that's a fabulous
grouping of three players McCaffrey
though joining my buddy Marshall Faulk
and Roger Craig is the only thousand
thousand rusher and receiver running
backs in the same season that's a that's
a pretty hefty number to try and compete
with despite what Henry was able to do
with Nick Chubb go down to the last game
of the year for the rushing title
well what Christian did it with two is
you know he had a head coach get fired
in December he had you know two
offensive coordinators he had Cam Newton
will Grier you know Allen you know two
rookie quarterbacks what he did it with
is truly amazing without a real
number-one threat outside you have to
worry about it receiver where every
defense just focused on him and I think
back to my last year a second last year
in Arizona
David Johnson was so close to getting a
thousand a thousand we went into the LA
Coliseum to play against the Rams week
17 I think David had like you know a
thousand eleven hundred yards rushing he
had like nine hundred and forty yards
receiving and we went in with a game
plan to get him the ball to get him back
thousand yards receiving and he ended up
hurting his knee like with three minutes
left in the first quarter and didn't get
it so I saw firsthand how difficult it
is it happened right in front of my eyes
and we we were forcing him the ball and
trying to get him a thousand a thousand
I just saw how just difficult it is
weekend week out touching the ball that
many times taking those hits and for
Christian to do it with two head you
know two different head coaches multiple
coordinators multiple quarterbacks there
was truly just a fantastic year by him
yeah sure was do you know Carson how
many career rushing yards you had you
like you may be asked me that before and
I've been hitting the head so many times
that my short-term memory okay not that
good no I'm gonna say around around a
hundred no come on no no no no no
oh you don't you are you're a tremendous
lout you weren't just a regular [ __ ]
don't wear your tremendous slouch 474
career rushing yards on 301 totes Carson
though we will do the math for you
that's a point six three yards per carry
in your career shabby that's easy for a
half a Canadian kid from Southern
California so do you remember any what
your longest run was do you remember
that one
I remember my longest run in college I
ripped off like a 50-yarder against UCLA
in the Rose Bowl but it was because they
were playing prevent defense yeah I was
gonna throw a Hail Mary I just decided
not to throw it because I don't want
throw the pick and I ended up having the
longest run of my career but I don't I
don't remember my loss according to this
this whether it's pro football reference
so they get everything right you ripped
off a 16 yarder as a 37 year old and
you're second to last year in the
National Football League you probably
you know six to seven miles per if you
were to if you were to have a gun on me
man Carson Palmer here on the Rich Eisen
show you are a perfect guest to try and
I guess solve the Jameis Winston riddle
here Carson because the Bruce Arians
offense usually does lead to a high rate
of interceptions for the quarterback in
his first year in that system you threw
a career-high 22 of them back in 2013
for Ariens and we saw this year Jameis
said the 34 30 that you don't want to
have what what is it about the aryans
offense Carson you know I just think you
know deep down inside you know Bruce
knows it's so hard in today's day and
game you know in today's day and age to
put together 85 yard drives that are 15
play 16 17 18 play drives just hard to
do defenses are so good he what he likes
those three or four play drives with the
60 yard touchdown pass and you know he's
he's you know he's famous for saying you
know no risk it no biscuit
you know he wants his quarterbacks to
play with that mentality and you look
back at some of some of James's picks I
mean he hit some receivers dead in the
hands or in the chest and it bounced off
their hands and went to a defender so
they're not all on him I mean not not
all 30 or all on him and very rarely are
all the picks on the quarterback but
when you drop back and throw it 40-plus
times a game you really focus on the
passing game and really don't run the
ball as much as most quarterbacks would
like two picks are gonna happen but
you've got to take those chances
especially if you're not real good on
defense like Tampa Bay was and they knew
they were going to get some points
scored on them they had to take those
shots Jameis had to take some you know
take some opportunities to throw some
balls and some tight windows and
unfortunately more often not you know
those balls seemed to get picked by him
but that's just the mentality to Bruce
plays with he's not going to run the
ball 35 times a game and and try to win
a game 17 to 13 he's going to go out
there and he's going to try to you know
throw the ball and jam the ball down
down the field and throw the ball over
your head and try to score 40 points
every week well the next year you
certainly got a better hang of it just
three interceptions for you the
following year and obviously you had an
injury marred season then you come back
and when you are starter again this was
the year where you you made the deepest
run in the playoffs just 11 so you kind
of cut it in half in the same amount of
time that you played what gives you any
sense that perhaps Jameis might have the
same level of success in year two and
his full year Carson I believe he'll
have a big jump if he's back in Tampa
with Bruce I really believe he'll he'll
come back because it's such a difficult
mentally it's such a difficult offense
it is not easy there are tons of
formations tons of shifts every play can
change the line of scrimmage protection
wise there's so many different concepts
we would go into game plans I know Tampa
went into game plans with the
possibility of having you know three to
four hundred plays come off the play
sheet so it's not a simple offense you
know you watch you watch Baltimore play
and you watch some these teams that are
just dynamic on offense and and they're
putting in each game plan probably half
my
place that brew scary so it's not a
simple offense to just pick up and and
start off year one and go out there and
have a Pro Bowl year it takes years it
takes years for the quarterback and it
takes six years for the guys outside
because there's you know there's
multiple opportunities where receivers
have the option to run one of two routes
and it doesn't they don't make that
decision and make that cut until they
get to the top of the route and that's
just something you need time you need
you need experience within that system
and that's something you don't have you
don't have that experience in year 1 you
need year 1 to go back and watch the
film and see yourself doing it wrong and
the receivers seeing themselves do it
wrong and then year to really things
start to click and that that chemistry
starts to develop and that trust and and
that confidence in the offense starts to
develop so if Jameis is back in Tampa I
would expect year 2 to be a massive year
for him again the first pair of Pro Bowl
teammates in Evans and Godwin since
Anquan Boldin and Larry Fitzgerald in
2009 for for the Arizona Cardinals the
team that went to the Super Bowl before
you arrived there that said you also
need a thick skin Carson I mean with
with Aryans after the game in which the
season ended on a pick six to give
Jameis the 30th interception of the
season Aryans
when asked about Winston says you look
at it and there's so much good and so
much outright terrible I mean like
literally he puts everything on the
table like that
what was the difficult part of that
process for you and Bruce when you were
together oh well that's nothing I mean
what he said to the open media is
nothing compared to what he probably
said to Jameis and the things he said to
me over the years I mean you're the guy
with the beat button would be holding
that thing down for a duration of the
conversation probably so yeah I mean
thick-skinned there's some every
quarterback needs to have extra extra
thick skin and some every Bruce Arians
quarterback needs to have because the
stuff he says the media is is rated G
compared to the stuff he says to to your
face on the sidelines and after team the
locker room throughout the week but you
know he knows how important each
quarterbacks the
skin is he knows the importance of being
able to move past a really bad throw or
a really bad decision and be able to
make a great decision the next one so he
you know it starts in OTAs it goes
through training camp obviously
throughout the season that's how he
coaches and that's how he tries to get
the best out of his players he's not you
know high-fiving and hug in and and
saying you know blowing smoke he's he's
real and he's authentic and he gets
after you and he puts you in tough
situations on purpose so maybe if you
need a little thicker skin he puts you
in situations where you can grow that
thicker skin so I hope Jameis gets
another shot with them because I think
we'll see a much better year year to
Carson Palmer here on the Rich Eisen
show courtesy of our friends at FedEx
you want to ask him the poll question
before we send him out and the rest of
the day there Christopher yeah Carson
which quarterback under the most
pressure this weekend divisional round
weekend Lamar Jackson
deshaun Watson Kirk Cousins Jimmy
Garoppolo what about Aaron Rodgers okay
what's your thoughts on that then if you
want to go over the most pressure with
the way things went down with Mike
McCarthy with the way things started off
with with his new coach and Green Bay
you know there's there's been shots
taken kind of by everybody but he
doesn't win enough that he's he's not
really the greatest or one of the
greatest because he doesn't win enough I
just feel like this is such a big year
in such a big postseason maybe the
biggest postseason of his career
including the year he won the Super Bowl
I'm kidding um I just feel like he's got
the most pressure on him because he's
got he's got a higher seed he's at home
he's Aaron Rodgers you know he's
everybody's touted him as being one of
the greatest ever if he's going to be
one of the greatest ever and he's going
to hold on
hold on to that then then this is a big
game obviously next week and a Superbowl
be big if they get that far but I just
feel like it's had the most pressure on
him throughout the year just with the
way last year ended and with with all
the accolades he's gotten over the years
well I mean it's interesting take their
Carson cuz I think he's one of the most
overlooked quarterbacks one would think
because his coach of the year doesn't
get any credit for his coach doesn't get
any credit for coach of the year because
Aaron's
a goat and he's just rolling the
footballs out and yet Aaron Rodgers
doesn't get any MVP talk because
apparently he's not as good anymore so
the you know those are the two
statements you hear that you can't
really square in a circle you know so
it's been interesting that you would out
of everybody say you know what I don't
want even want to go for any guys that
you put up there you'll go for Aaron
Rodgers well if I had to pick of the
other guys okay
probably Russell Wilson just because he
has the most on his shoulders he has to
he has to play perfectly to win he
doesn't have the threats outside that
he's had in the past he doesn't have
that defense that he had in the past
he's got Marshawn back who hasn't played
football for really two years so he's
got probably of the polled players he's
got the most pressure on him just
because he probably has the least amount
of weapons around him but I just feel
like it was all that's going on within
you know people talking about him being
the goat and and Brady's cat seven
there's six Super Bowls he's got a lot
to prove and I think he's definitely
feeling it I think he's very excited
about this opportunity but I think he
realizes that if he's one and done this
this year and the playoffs
there's gonna be a lot of repercussions
that are they're gonna be heading his
way the sausage well you just put the
pressure on on Chris Brockman and the
rest of our production staff here
because Russell wasn't a choice on that
poll question maybe we have to redo our
health question we came up with four
guys that you thought read him one more
time
Marv Jackson the presumptive MVP deshaun
Watson who had to do it all himself last
week Kirk Cousins everyone said can't
win the big game and Jimmy Garoppolo has
really never been tested okay okay just
Jimmy G cuz everybody feels like the
team is so good except for the
quarterback and he's got to prove
everybody wrong that the team is so good
because of the quarterback okay Carson
well done sir
FedEx
in FedEx Ground Player of the Year
nominees are out go and check them out
at nfl.com slash FedEx voting is open
you can vote all the way up until the
Thursday before the Superbowl and the
winners will be announced at NFL honors
in Miami on Saturday February 1st and
then FedEx is gonna make a donation
totaling up to $40,000 to the USO in the
name of both the winning quarterback and
running back Thank You Carson Palmer
appreciate the time man Thank You hos
good to catch up thanks for having right
back at you that's Carson Palmer right
here on the Rich Eisen show for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel - 39 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app